[Music]
I'm an excise physiologist I'm diabetes
educator I'm living with diabetes how
could I not share this information you
adopt this plant-based Whole Food
plant-based approach like how quickly
before you started to uh you know
perceive these results and realize that
you were on to something pretty powerful
maybe two weeks in my numbers were back
to normal I mean two that sounds like
even when I think about it now that's
very fast I couldn't believe how quickly
it happened and I was able to maintain
I'm 5 years in now and I've maintaining
the same instant sensitivity I'm eating
you know hundreds of grams of
carbohydrates didn't wither away and
lose all my muscle you know my my I was
very happy with my gym performance and
my sporting performance and how I feel
and just the whole list you know I I I
was very very nervous about a few things
there and thankfully I I was I was wrong